[Music]
good evening I'm Jack lemon the Irving
Thalberg Irving G Thalberg award is the
most unique honor that the Academy can
bestow it is the only a major award that
is not an Oscar as you can see it is a
bust of a young genius who died at the
age of 37 and left behind a remarkable
legacy of movies that he had produced or
otherwise nurtured and it is also the
heaviest award that we give Paul Berg
died in 1936 and within a year the Board
of Governors voted to keep his name and
his ideals alive by creating a special
award that would be given from time to
time to an individual normally a
producer whose body of work showed the
same passionate commitment to quality
that had marched all Berg's career in
1937 they gave the first Irving Thalberg
award to Darryl zanuck and in the 50
years since they have seen fit to award
it to just 24 other individuals so mere
mortals need not apply the roster of
past Thalberg award recipients includes
David O Selznick walt disney Hal Wallis
Sam Goldwyn George Stevens Sam Spiegel
the list runs on to include William
Wyler Robert Wise Alfred Hitchcock
Ingmar Bergman and last year's recipient
Steven Spielberg now the man that we are
honoring tonight maybe a little sardonic
about this whole thing but oh he will
fit right in with the crowd that he is
joining he is a man who has chalked up
an even dozen nominations for
screenwriting another eight for
directing and he may have to get a new
mantelpiece to hold this little sucker
because the one he's got now already has
six Oscars on it he has produced some of
the most memorable and remarkable
pictures that this industry has ever
made a master of the art of the movies
unfailingly true to himself and his
audience ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
thank you very much I understand that
this is the most prestigious of what you
can get with the possible exception of
the Nobel Prize of thought I would like
it to take this because I repeat brick I
would especially like to thank after
having thanked the the governors of the
of the Academy and the members and all
the millions of fans I have all over the
world in in the civilized parts of the
world
I would tell very much like to thank one
specific gentleman without whose help I
would not be standing here tonight I
forgot his name but I have never
forgotten his compassion he was the
American Council in Mexicali Mexico I
imagine it's 1934 it's a year after the
Hitler puch we are all in exile Zurich
London Paris then I get lucky I set a
story to Hollywood and I get a visitor's
visa for six months then I come here and
start working but six months go by very
very fast well I don't want to leave I
would like to stay in America so I I am
big dope that I need an immigration visa
for which reason you I mean you have to
leave the country get the immigration
visa and then come back in order to
reenter with the proper papers so I go
to Mexicali which is the closest
American consulate right over there
across the border from California and as
they showed me into the office affair of
the of the council I was I was drenched
in sweat was not the heat it was just a
panic the fear I knew that I needed a a
whole bunch of documents affidavits
official proof of former residents
shuang Testaments that I had never been
a criminal or an anarchist
I had nothing zilch just my passport and
my my
my birth certificate and from letters
from a few American friends vouching
that I was harmless it looked hopeless
the council he looked a little bit like
like Will Rogers examined my meager
documentation is that all you have he
asked and I said yes I have to explain
that you know I had to get out of Berlin
on very short notice like 20 minutes a
neighbor had tipped me off that that two
men in uniform had been looking for me
at just enough time to to slow in the
few things in the suitcase and get on
the night train to Paris the council
just stared at me and said I mean how do
you expect me to with just those papers
and I told him I tried to get them
attacked from denies from Nazi Germany
but they just would not respond of
course I could get them if I if I if I
went back to Germany then they would put
me naturally on the train and to ship me
off to Dachau so he just kept staring
and staring at me and i i i i was not
sure what i was getting through to him i
have heard of whole families who have
spent years they are waiting for the
visa and other guys who never got it and
to believe me i wanted to get back to
America it looked bad so we just sit
there and stared at each other the
council and I in total silence finally
asked me what do you do I mean
professionally and I said there I write
movies he said that so he got up and
started pacing kind of behind me but I
felt that he was measuring me then he
came back to the desk picked up my past
but opened it and took the rubber stamp
and when handed me back the passport and
he said I write some good ones that was
54 years ago
I've tried ever since
as certainly I certainly did not want to
disappoint the dear man in mexicali
enter you know as I look back and I've
lived a charmed life
I never expected something like this
like they thought about the world you
are without any doubt this the most
generous people in the world and I hope
you're watching IAL because part of this
is yours
so get well will you thank you very very
much
[Applause]
you